bonsoir et merci de nous avoir rejoints
pour cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 une
édition 100 % féminine à la veille de la
journée internationale des femmes dans
quelques instants nous parlerons
justement des droits de ces femmes avec
l'association elle aussi et le centre
d'information des droits des femmes et
des familles
nous recevrons également une couturière
qui a longtemps été habilleuse au moulin
rouge alors forcément elle aura plein
d'anecdotes à nous raconter et puis dans
une petite trentaine de minutes ce sera
la page aequo avec vous car cambier
bonsoir et on va parler des femmes chefs
d'entreprise soit là c'est logique à
cette chronique économique les femmes
seront aussi à l'honneur
nous recevrons deux chefs d'entreprise
l'une est à la tête de rollingbox une
agence de communication digitale l'autre
gère planète langue un institut de
formation en langues de femmes qui se
sont démarqués par leur parcours
professionnel puisque parmi les artisans
commerçants chefs d'entreprises des
civils
on ne comptabilise que 26% des femmes
merci est clair donc rendez vous ici une
petite demi heure mais d'abord je
propose de retrouver les titres les
sujets qui seront développés au cours de
la prochaine heure jean marc ayrault
vient de rendre ses conclusions dans le
dossier du grand paris a donné son
accord pour la réalisation de 200
kilomètres de lignes de métro autour de
paris un projet décalé à 2030 avec des
économies à la clé quelles conséquences
pour les yvelines
l'accord de compétitivité pour renault a
été validé et signée par deux syndicats
la cfe cgc et fo un projet qui prévoit
le maintien des usines en france en
échange d'efforts durable demandé aux
salariés réactions notamment
technocentre de guyancourt
et puis vous allez découvrir en quelques
instants le gel de vous ne savez
peut-être pas ce que signifient ces
initiales gérald pour groupement
d'exploration de longue durée nous avons
suivi une séance d'entraînement de ces
pompiers qui interviennent notamment
dans les tunnels
et puis à la veille de la journée
internationale des femmes le portrait de
corinne gastaud elle est femme chef
d'entreprise dans un monde
dom pour une gastro est en effet à la
tête d'une société de déménagement à
trappes
mais tout d'abord je vous propose donc
un retour sur cet accord de
compétitivité signée par deux syndicats
chez renault les syndicats justement qui
réagissent anthony rech le timing est
parfait le jour où le gouvernement
adopte le projet de loi sur l'accord
interprofessionnel
renault tient la signature de deux
syndicats pour entériner son projet de
compétitivité après la cfe cgc force
ouvrière lui a emboîté le pas ce
mercredi j'espère qu'on va gagner je
suivrai trois ans et au bout de trois
ans s'est très bien passé on nous parle
de 2007 dans un premier temps voire 2020
donc voiture et qu'on est déjà
pratiquement garantie jusqu'en 2020 bon
ils capturent des voitures de nos
partenaires milton et puis certainement
des moeurs la direction de la marque au
losange s'engage à ne fermer aucun site
et à ne pas adopter de plan social pour
y arriver
l'accord prévoit d'augmenter la
production française avec au moins sept
cent dix mille véhicules par an dont 110
milles à l' usine de flins en
contrepartie les salariés acceptent
d'augmenter leur rythme de travail
passant de 32 à 35 heures est de voir
leur salaire gelé en 2013 contrairement
à la volonté de l'entreprise malgré ses
engagements pris jusqu'en 2016 la cgt
reste fermement opposée au projet
au-delà de ces deux véhicules jo et et
clio 4 qui sont produits dans l'usiné de
flins
aujourd'hui dans l'avenir plus lointain
au delà de 2016 il n'y a pas de véhicule
aujourd'hui dans les tiroirs de renault
qui pourrait rentrer dans le gym de
flins d'ici à 2016 plus de 8200 postes
seront tout de même supprimé le projet
sera présenté le 12 mars en conseil
central d'entreprise il pourrait être
signé dès le lendemain
le 8 mars vous le savez c'est la journée
internationale des femmes une journée
qui est apparu tout d'abord dans un
contexte de mouvements sociaux au
tournant du xxème siècle en amérique du
nord et en europe
et puis c'est en 1975 lors de l'année
internationale de la femme que
l'organisation des nations unies l'onu a
commencé à célébrer donc cette journée
internationale de la femme le 8 mars
alors avant d'en parler avec nos invités
que je salue lui c'est romain bonsoir
vous êtes directrice du centre
d'information du droit des femmes et des
familles et françoise pelissolo bonsoir
vous êtes l'ancien président de l eau si
vous avez été engagé en politique avec
vous évidemment on parlera de la parité
en politique
je vous propose donc cette première
phrase elle est signée de ban ki moon le
secrétaire général des nations unies qui
dit la violence à l'égard des femmes
n'est jamais acceptable jamais excusable
jamais tolérable ça c'est une phrase
forte et mesdames je suis sûr vous la
partagez cette phrase forcément bien su
forcer mais elle est négative
cette prouve que la violence existe oui
tout à fait elle est sous la forme
négative la violence existe toujours
vécu si robin vous allez nous en parler
dans quelques instants
une journée des droits des femmes c'est
important nous on est des femmes pour
défendre les droits des femmes c'est
important mais c'est très important on
l'a vu au fil des siècles puisque quand
on voit où en sont les femmes en france
en particulier mais pas seulement dans
le monde
on va parler des violences ça c'est sûr
des droits qui sont supprimés dans des
tas de pays
il faut penser qu'en france le droit de
vote il n'a enfin il a un peu plus d'un
siècle seulement maintenant et
l'éligibilité qui va avec
malheureusement
elle est très très difficile à obtenir
donc pour nous la parité c'est à dire la
présence des femmes élues dans les modes
on décide c'est à dire les assemblées
législatives en particulier c'est ce qui
conditionnera le soutien à tous les
autres droits
il n'ya que lorsqu'il y aura des femmes
qui ont voté dès l'abord lyon les haut
rang qui les feront appliquée qu'ils
pourront qui seront en situation de
surveiller leurs applications qu'on
verra disparaître j'espère les violences
et tout ce qui est la diminution de la
personnalité les femmes donc les droits
des femmes peuvent tout le temps par le
droit je pense au départ on a pensé le
contraire et on s'est rendu compte que
leur fallait miser sur la peau verte est
juste question sur le journée
internationale des femmes il en faut une
journée internationale des femmes selon
vous oui c'est important qu'ils aient
cette journée parce que c'est vrai que
c'est un moment où on va sensibiliser
les personnes à l'évolution des droits
des femmes à l'état de la situation
aujourd'hui parce qu'on a des droits
certes mais après ce qu'ils sont
vraiment respectée donc c'est important
de sensibiliser après j'aurais tendance
à dire que la journée de la femme c'est
bien mais ça doit être tous les jours
samba seulement lui marsan faut lutter
pour les rôles à la proposition de najat
vallaud de valo parlant belkacem à la
ministre des droits des femmes de faire
une action tous les jours pendant 365
jours vous êtes favorable consentir des
solos j'espère contiendra une année ou
bien tout sera résolu en moins d'un an
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup à
faire en tout cas c'est original en l
adhésion du côté du gouvernement de
françois hollande est effectivement on a
voulu de fer 7e journée de la femme plus
long sur une année complète plutôt
qu'une seule journée du 10 mars
en tout cas nous sommes nous sommes
allés dans les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines pour demander aux habitants si
une journée pour défendre les droits des
femmes c'était important on écoute leur
réponse oui je veux que c'est important
parce que
dans certains endroits sur la planète la
femme n'est pas forcément respectée donc
je pense une journée dans l'année c'est
bien mérité
je pense que c'est important parce que
ça va mettre en lumière tout ce qui se
fait tout au long de l'année passée
important parce qu'en fait bon c'est
quand même un signe très fort quoi voilà
et puis la femme c'est quelque chose
dans une vie c'est c'est indispensable
c'est voilà c'est du bonheur oui je
pense que la position de la femme n'est
pas encore assez importante dans notre
société qui est encore assez
inégalitaire d'un point de vue de la
parité des sexes pas forcément je pense
que tout le monde a des des droits etc
donc j'en ai de la femme ça devrait être
principalement le titane et qu enfin
pour tout le monde quoi pour moi c'est
important qu'il y ait une journée dédiée
à la femme
et j'aimerais bien que maintenant on
passe un peu à autre chose et qu'on dise
que les femmes les hommes c'est vraiment
égal
voilà aussi des réactions très positives
merci à ces messieurs qui ont des
réactions très très positif lucie robin
j'ai dit vous êtes directrice du centre
d'information des droits des femmes et
des familles d yves les quel type de
problème
les femmes qui viennent nous voir sont
confrontés quel type de problème mais
principalement fait on fait des
permanences juridiques quand elles se
présentent dans les permanences
juridiques
c'est essentiellement des problèmes en
matière familiale donc des situations de
rupture de des problèmes autour de
l'autorité parentale également des
problématiques de violences au sein du
couple
donc ça sur l'année 2012 on a eu 621 une
femme qui se sont présentés pour cette
problématique
donc c'est beaucoup à vous dire
pratiquement 2 par jour si vous êtes
ouvert tous les jours de l'année voilà
c'est ça mon ans c'est énorme donc
donc voilà ça c'est sûr le volet plus
sur les permanences juridiques
après sur le volet emploi c'est beaucoup
des problématiques de femmes qui se sont
arrêtées de travailler ou qui n'ont
jamais travaillé et qui souhaitent
retourner à l'emploi donc là elles sont
accompagnées en fait dans le retour à
l'emploi et on travaille surtout les
freins rencontrés à l'emploi c'est à
dire pas seulement travailler le projet
professionnel
mais avant ça à travailler sur l'estimé
de soi sur les questions de mobilité de
garde d'enfants à ça c'est des
problématiques auxquelles est fermé
c'est amusant jeu amusant c'est
peut-être pas vraiment le mot mais ce
qui est étonnant quand même c'est que
d'année en année
quand on invite votre association ce
genre d'association on entend toujours
les mêmes choses
tertio les femmes quand elles elles ont
eu un enfant qu'elles ont dû s'arrêter
qu'elles doivent reprendre le chemin du
travail va elles sont obligées de se
battre pour retrouver leur chemin du
travail
le travail c'est quand maria les volumes
où il ya des choses quand même positif
non non les choses les choses évoluent
et heureusement mais c'est vrai qu'après
on se retrouve confronté depuis quelques
années de plus en plus de précarité et
c'est vrai que ce sont les femmes qui
sont touchés en premier lieu puisque
quand on regarde les familles
monoparentales à 85% ce sont des femmes
et ce sont telles qu'on reçoit dans nos
permanences et ce sont elles qui
rencontrent des problèmes d'emploi les
problèmes de ruptures familiales etc
brême de non paiement de pension
alimentaire enfin tout ça c'est des
problématiques on et auxquels on est
confrontés tous les jours et ça fait 30
ans que le cidf agit sur le secteur des
yvelines et 30 ans que ces
problématiques reviennent mais peut-être
plus encore depuis quelques années
notamment sur les problématiques
d'emploi beaucoup de situations de
licenciement de femmes qui sont en
amélioration
alors vous vous traitez du droit des
femmes même si vous avez l'impression
que les femmes sont plus fragiles entre
guillemets sur le terrain de l'emploi
que les hommes
oui mais peut-être les poussées pour
tenter de les pousser dehors de
l'entreprise en temps c'est de faire de
la pression psychologique sur une femme
que sur un homme
mais après en fait ce qui se passe c'est
qu'elles sont sur-représentés dans tout
ce qui est travail à temps partiel
on a une explosion du nombre de femmes
dans le secteur tertiaire fin sur des
des métiers sous qualifiés donc voilà
donc à elles sont en fait précarisés au
niveau de l'emploi ça soit pas forcément
parce qu'elles apparaissent en emploi
mais elles sont dans les temps partiels
sont ce qu'elles sont des qualifiés par
rapport à leur diplôme
elles ont du mal à accéder à des années
au poste
le problème du plafond de verre donc
voilà c'est ce qu'on rencontre des
preuves de ces rencontres est encore des
problèmes d un référentiel de salaire
dont 27% donc a donc oui tout à fait il
ya encore des grosses fort médiatique
donc on sensibilise aussi assez en
collectif parce que effectivement on va
dire oui enfin en france les femmes ont
des droits
c'est bon sauf que c'est écrit dans les
textes des textes sont là en fait
l'arsenal législatif est grand mais
n'est pas forcément respectée
donc on est là pour ça pour agir là
dessus et concerne les violences
vous avez donné ce chiffre assez
important de 626 1,21 à des doses qui
sont venus vous voir
on a l'impression qu'à pareil c'est pas
on en parle des violences ont dit à quel
moment il faut que les femmes soient
authentiques elles voient là et malgré
tout il ya toujours ces problématiques
de violence oui tout à fait ouais simple
et là on en est même plus eu en 2012
qu'en 2011 on ait une augmenter ces
journées c'est peut-être à la précarité
c'est à dire à la fiabilité du foyer
ça peut être ça c'est aussi lié au fait
qu'on en parle peut-être plus qu'avant
ça sort parce qu'il ya eu toute une
époque où les violences ça devait rester
au sein de la famille on ne devait pas
en parler ça ne sortait pas du cadre
familial donc maintenant l'expriment
beaucoup plus et on n'arrive plus à
toucher les femmes
oui l'exprimer un petit peu plus c'est
ce que pense aussi chantal poli texier
ou vous la connaissez louis n'a cessé
ces voix là c'est la présidente
fondatrice de l'association agissez
contre la violence morale et
l'association vient justement de publier
un ouvrage pour évoquer les violences
morales un ouvrage qui s'adresse aussi
bien aux particuliers qu'aux
professionnels de la justice
elle définit avec nous cette violence
morale une vraie violence du quotidien
on écoute la violence morale pour nous
c'est un terme générique qu'on a
utilisées pour regrouper ce que d'aucun
homme le harcèlement moral d'autres la
manipulation et d'autres encore la
violence psychologique trois termes qui
regroupe des choses qui sont extrêmement
semblable
et puis aussi des petites nuances et
petite différence donc pour nous la
violence morale c'était c'était un terme
qui qui recouvrait tous les faits tous
les actes qui mettent sous emprise qui
met sous soumission
qui relève de 7 d'une forme de violence
qui est surtout invisible et insidieuse
la violence morale je pense qu'elle a
toujours existé simplement les je crois
que la société a évolué et surtout
les recherches ont été effectuées sur le
sujet il ya eu plein de parution et puis
les médias se sont aussi sont intéressés
et du coup c'est vrai que ça évolue
énormément c'est à dire qu'il ya de plus
en plus une prise en considération de
cette forme de violence qui était quand
même
méconnue et surtout considérer est
encore considéré d'ailleurs on va dire
honnêtement par beaucoup de
l'institutionnel comme une violence
mineurs la grande difficulté c'est de la
faire non seulement prendre en
considération complètement mais qu'on
arrête de dire que c'est une violence
légère parce que c'est loin d'être une
violence légère puisque sept des
structures et ça détruit la personnalité
même le fondement même de l'être humain
donc c'est loin d'être une violences
légères ces mêmes car elles s'habillent
qui a écrit la préface de notre livre a
dit que c'était la colonne vertébrale de
toutes les formes de violence je trouve
que c'est tout à fait juste parce que
c'est exactement ça donc
donc elle a toujours existé elle a fait
même partie de notre société à un moment
donné comme une norme en l'homme dominé
la fin mais c'était une norme
ça a changé ça a changé au niveau de nos
moeurs au niveau de la société
mais ça a quand même encore quelques
difficultés à être pleinement pris en
considération voilà ça évolue mais tout
doucement allez on va encore parler du
droit des femmes mais cette fois sous
l'angle politique avec vos françoise
pelissolo bonsoir vous êtes l'ancienne
présidente de l oc et merci surtout
d'être avec nous sur le plateau du 7-8
ce jeudi soir parce qu'en principe vous
étiez invité auprès de najat vallaud
belkacem la ministre des droits des
femmes pour le lancement d'une opération
le 8 mars et toute l'année on en a parlé
il ya quelques instants c'est donc une
opération qui veut associer les
associations c'est le cas de le dire
pour faire une action tous les jours de
l'année pendant un an
mais c'est surtout un rassemblement
d'associations autour de la ministre qui
a montré qu'elle ait des dynamiques et
qu'elle voulait faire avancer les choses
même depuis qu'elle a été nommée
ministre et qui sera honoré sa
semblement par la présence du président
de la république lorsque dommage c'est
que vous vouliez pause mthethwa françois
hollande va dire non je rendrai une
question publiquement alors pas de
raison mais disons que je les connais
depuis toutes ces années où à ses côtés
et derrière on lui rappelait que la
parité ça existe et qu'il faut en tenir
compte
donc on est très content de voir qu'il a
fait avancer maintenant un gouvernement
alors justement le projet de loi sur la
parité actuellement en débat au
parlement
s'il est adopté ça c'est un véritable
changement profond notamment pour les
élections municipales parce que dans un
an c'est 2014 et les élections
municipales et ça veut dire qu'il y aura
en gros la parité obligatoire sur la
liste dans les communes à partir de 500
habitants pour l'instant c'est
uniquement à partir de 3500 habitants
ont envie de voir ça va ça pourrait
changer la face de la france ça pourrait
changer ça n'est pas la loi sur la
parité qui a été voté avec la
modification de la constitution il est
déjà 20
oui dix ans tout au moins mais cette
fois ci c'est une loi qui doit aller
plus au fond des choses parce qu on
s'aperçut comme vous le disiez que les
textes existent mais elles sont pas
appliquées en politique il faut bien
voir comme plus encore que dans toute la
société les femmes ne sont pas bien
considérés mais surtout elles veulent
des places qui sont occupés par des
hommes des places de pouvoir donc un
siège de moins pour un homme pour donner
à une femme c'est insupportable on sait
bien qu'il va falloir les remplacer ceux
qui sont excédentaires par rapport à la
parité sans fondement plus que la parité
mais c'est un peu dommage quand même
qu'il faille passer par le principe de
la loi depuis 2000 et qu'on a changé la
loi justement tout le monde dit mais
pourquoi faire une loi
quand on l'a préparé on se disait aussi
c'est pas possible on va essayer de
mieux faire appliquer devant les
tribunaux on a cherché toutes les
solutions en avait tout les juristes
possible des universitaires qui avait
travaillé sur la question c'est vraiment
un immense réseau qui se fait autour de
la loi par pour la parité et on s'est
rendu compte que non on arrivait même à
revenir en arrière la loi qui modifia
l'élection au sénat il ya quelques
années était déjà une régression et le
chiffre de 3500 que vous citez ça tient
en fait à la loi électorale existant
auparavant
il ya des catégories de communes à
partir de 3500 est en dessous 3500 donc
nous avions déjà demandé à l'époque que
ce soit 1000 et ça a été refusé parce
que je dois mourir sans précédent et on
arrive à 500 ce qui est presque
stupéfiant quand on a connu les lois
précédentes
vous avez des chiffres sur les yvelines
là on a pendant que vous parliez on a vu
trois personnages féminine célèbre du
département valérie pécresse il ya un
mois la présidente de la fédération ump
du département
on a vu aussi joséphine costes émerger
une nouvelle merde de plaisir
trente mille habitants il me semble de
mémoire que c'est la seule femme maire
d'une ville
les habitants de 39 ans habitant je suis
pas assuré
et puis là on voit les raffineurs qui
était maire de velars des questions à
fontenay je veux pas la même population
mais on a quand même de plus en plus
alors que il ya vingt ans quand nous
avons commencé elle aussi s'était 24
femmes maires sur 262 et maintenant et
bien maintenant on est à 42 des 43 à la
maintenant avec les toutes dernières
donc on arrive mais vingt ans pour en
arriver là et on est loin du compte de
la parité bien sûr c'était dans les
petites communes parce que là elles ne
sont pas indemnisés ya pas de confort de
travail a pas de gros services
techniques
c'est un pur dévouement le maire il est
dévoué sa commune on vient de solliciter
pour tous sans grand avantage
confortable je dis donc une loi sur la
parité qui passe par les élections
municipales vu aussi concerner les les
conseillers inter intercommunes
économique gie oui mais la question
c'est comment mobiliser les femmes
comment les inciter à s'engager en
politique alors c'est tout travail de
notre association nous ne sommes pas
contentés de donner les chiffres de
dénoncer les carences mais dès le départ
6 des femmes devait d'y aller il fallait
leur donner leur en donné l'envi et on
voit bien dans ces conditions là peu de
femmes sont prêtes à moins une ambition
dévorante qu'on place généralement
ailleurs ou dans sa profession ou dans
les associations
peu de femmes avaient envie de se lancer
dans un
un défi pareil donc l'idée c'était
conseillère municipale pourquoi pas vous
on a commencé par les communes parce que
c'était une façon plus facile mais avec
l'idée essentielle qu'il fallait monter
à tous les niveaux avoir un réservoir un
vivier de femmes élues à la base pour
enfin prétendre avoir la parité à
l'assemblée nationale par exemple au
sénat et le mode de scrutin ne s'y prête
pas du tout à l'assemblée donc il faudra
là aussi surfer mobilisés pour mary
sammons mars 2014 avec une à la question
vous avez été candidate en juin 2000 us
aux élections sur la 10e circonscription
d'un dj et vénale aux 900 la 10e
circonscription des yvelines
circonscription de gérard larcher sur
près de poisson c'est facile d'exister
en politique il faut dire que l'élection
de toute façon il était difficile
qu'elle existe parce qu'elle a été
décidée en plein milieu de l'été et le
vote ayant lieu début septembre
tout le monde était en vacances et est
ce que vous dans la campagne dans cette
campagne dont vous avez souffert de
discrimination parce que vous étiez une
femme
vous allez me dire bord c'est un débat
dépasse et franchement c'est à droite
que dans les partis politiques
c'est difficile mais enfin j'avais la
chance d'appartenir à un parti qui veut
la parité et que de l'intérieur ont des
fidèles appliquer réellement la parité
puisque on l'a voulu on l'a votée il
faut l'appliquer maintenant c'est
toujours difficile il ya des hommes qui
a qui prétendent avoir leur place
mais quel que soit le parti de toute
façon une femme parce que la parité est
le mot qu'il faut tout de même appliquer
un petit peu a du mal
a débordé le cadre qu'on lui attribue
moi dans mon cas c'était différent
c'était les vacances c'était pareil pour
tout le monde et puis c'est un scrutin
uninominal donc la personnalité qu'on a
connus sur le terrain compte aussi un
peu pour quelqu'un tu serais pas connu
du tout c'est peut-être plus difficile
enfin les femmes elles sont actives
partout et on trouve facilement des
candidates
le problème c'est de leur donner la
possibilité de faire élire en tout elle
qui avait des femmes a en plus
nombreuses ce scrutin là donc il faut
appeler à mobiliser des femmes pour les
anticipations leur donner leur avis et
leur dire si l on vient c'est gratifiant
oui donc merci à vous d'être venu sur le
plateau 17,8 et toujours sur cette même
thématique du droit des femmes je
voudrais vous parler d'un site internet
qui va être lancée à partir de ce jeudi
qui s'appelle les trois w ivg les
adresses point org un site financé par
l' agence régionale de santé d'île de
france et qui recense les lieux
francilien où il est possible de se voir
pratiquer un avortement et on sait que
c'est parfois un peu devenu un peu
difficile je vois que mes invités aussi
de la dette donc j'ai bien raison et
puis à noter que la ville de la verrière
est toujours très mobilisés autour de
cette journée de la femme
plusieurs manifestations vont se
dérouler demain vendredi au scarabée un
repas le midi suivie d'un film et d'un
débat autour de l'engagement finir ça
vous à ça va vous intéresser françoise
pelissolo une exposition de
photographies à spectacle d'élèves
également pour terminer la journée voilà
c'est donc le 8 mars à partir de midi au
scarabée à la verrière on va poursuivre
ses études avec un sucre qui n'a rien à
voir mais qui parlent de femmes aussi on
va parler de princesses et programmes
aux oubliés de dire une chose très vite
on sensibilise les femmes il faut
beaucoup de femmes de tous les partis de
tous les bords bien notre oui je suis
pluraliste avant tout comme entre sa
base et ça s'entendait comme sa partie
levé vous voilà et on va continuer sur
cette suite avec un sujet de princesse
jeudi rosa soares va me rejoindre dans
quelques instants et elle a suivi un
atelier de costumes à magnifier les
hameaux elle a rencontré notamment
juliette kostyuk est elle aussi va nous
rejoindre dans quelques instants
les petites mains s'affairent autour de
l'est la fillette a imaginé sa robe de
princesse rouge avec des fleurs et des
tresses colorer son rêve devient réalité
grâce à l'atelier costumes organisée
cette semaine à l'estaminet café de
magny les hameaux pour la conseiller
elle et ses copines une ancienne
habilleuse du moulin rouge joue le rôle
de la bonne fée les princesses à son
princesse a raison tous les temps de se
faire belle
parce qu'elles sont et ce qu'ils aient
des françaises plus belles les unes que
les autres
les petites ont déjà appris à
confectionner un panier en rotin pour
donner du volume à leurs jupes de crépon
maintenant elle lui apportent des
touches girly à l'aide de décorations
faites à la main il faut rendre le
travail d'ici vendredi où ils auront un
petit défilé
donc il faut être préparé n'a encore pas
fait les coiffes et on n'a pas non plus
inventé les eaux qui seront reposés sur
leur t-shirt un il ya une valeur encore
beaucoup de travail beaucoup de mains
dépêchez-vous de savourer la vie à votre
intérieur des lieux
c'est aussi rapide oui mais à se
déchirer moins facilement
heureusement d'ailleurs alors mes chéris
vous remettez déflation vous reprenez y
en a pas tellement on change de couleur
à la fois directives et affectueuse
juliette costiou mène à la baguette des
futures princesses qui savent déjà ce
calvaire qui rouge
violet du bleu jeu marron humains vers
du rose et du violet
marine elle essaye de faire correctement
c'est sympa ça mais surtout c'est le but
à la fin ce vendredi les vingt petites
filles défilent dans leur tenue de rêve
précisons selon juliette costiou que
lorsque l'on porte de si belles
créations
interdiction de s'asseoir war et manger
pas facile la vie de princesse